dans l'actualité de ce 18 avril
également cette autre information le
ministère de l'Enseignement supérieur et
de la recherche dans une note interne se
penche sur les taux de réussite en
licence des universités françaises c'est
le site internet du nouvel Ops qui vient
de le rendre publique l'université de
Versailles 550 an en Yveline décroche la
note de 13,8 c'est notre chiffre du jour
il s'agit là d'une valeur ajoutée qui
prend en compte les résultats bien
évidemment mais aussi l'accompagnement
des étudiants et le fait d'avoir suivi
ou non l'ensemble de son cursus dans le
même établissement l'université
évelinoise termine ainsi à la première
place du classement devant anger midi
péréné également aucune université
parisienne dans le top 10 autre
enseignement ils sont 56,4 % à réussir
leur licence à Versailles Saint-Quentin
il s'agit là du 4e meilleur résultat
brut en France parmi les universités de
la métropole les moins bien classées
notamment celle de Paris 6 avec un taux
de 27,1 % seulement